Speaker 1: We have a voicemail
number. That number is 2192.
David P. Here's another voicemail about my
appearance on the Patrick David podcast.
Speaker 8: David, it's Allen from Jerry Lee. Yeah,
I don't know what the heck is. Going on with you.
But you're on some weird PB and J podcast,
and the right guy is like Joe Rogan, except
he's exactly like Joe Rogan, except he has
hair. Okay. And you're trying to tell him
how you were scamming people into buying
the the extra insurance at Circuit City
and. And he doesn't want to talk about that.
I mean, what the hell's going on with you,
David? I mean, you're moving to Florida, and
now you're swimming with the dolphins. You're
going to move into the villages with Pat and.
Speaker 1: Well, listen, I'm not going to the
villages, but I have to tell you, there is
something very appealing, very appealing
about getting out of the cold for 2 to 3 months
out of the year. Maybe I'll become a snowbird,
but if I did, it's going to have to be southern
Florida. I don't see myself as a Jacksonville guy.
But as far as the PBD appearance will be
publishing the whole thing to our YouTube
channel very soon, and I look forward to getting
more great feedback about it. PBD Is Joe Rogan
with Hair though is an interesting one. We've got
a great bonus show for you today. Sign up at join
Packman dot com. Don't miss it.
Unidentified: I'll see you then.